face coverings regular testing
and classroom bubbles not the school
days we're used to
but after months of lessons at the
kitchen table millions of children have
returned to the classroom today
as schools in england were given the
go-ahead to officially reopen
to all students this is covid and the
classroom
back to school
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
good evening after months of disruption
throughout the pandemic
students in england are now able to
return to the classroom
the prime minister called today an
emotional day the first stage of the
government's plan to ease lockdown
restrictions
in england with scotland wales and
northern ireland opting
for a phased reopening tonight we'll be
looking at what measures
have been put in place to keep children
and teachers safe
and assess the long-term implications on
education
and mental health and what's being done
to catch up
tonight i'll be joined by two panels
here we have a number of students
and a few parents who can tell us about
their first date back at school
and they'll be putting their questions
to our other panel where we have richard
sheriff the president
and ceo of red kite learning trust which
runs
13 schools in north and west yorkshire
he's also the executive head teacher of
harrogate grammar school
next to him we're streeting the shadow
minister for schools
and finally dr bernard kurt dubica chair
of the child and adolescent faculty at
the royal college of psychiatrists
welcome to you all well first of all
let's uh go to lewis
and josh seal louis is in year 11 so
doing gcses and josh
you're doing your a levels in that year
13.
how did it go first day back at school
lewis uh i think it is brilliant
it was so nice to have a change of
scenery from the bedroom and sitting at
your desk all day to suddenly being in a
classroom
actively learning alongside your peers
and it's so nice to actually be taught
by a teacher in person
rather than from a computer screen
joshie nodding your head there
yeah i'm going to agree with him i think
it was really nice to go and see friends
find me up for such a long time
um and yeah i think it definitely helps
having face-to-face contact with
features rather than
um you know online teaching okay we'll
be back to both of you
later in the program now on the first
ever
covid and the classroom in january we
heard from lauren
nolan and her two children frank and
bill the family like many
were battling through the pressures of
homeschooling well this morning frank
who's four
went back to school here's how their
morning went first day back at school
are you excited this morning is back to
school
um for frank who's in reception um all
yesterday he was saying
that he doesn't want to go back to
school he just wants to stay home
so um yeah hoping that he
is fine when he gets there
well such an exciting day many parents
myself hands up
very very keen to have school starting
back today
let's bring in pippa taylor now pippa's
in year six
hi pippa how did it go for you what was
it like being back with all your friends
um hi it was really nice to see everyone
and i got to work with my friends which
was
is much better than just typing into a
computer
oh i'm sure it is much better actually
seeing people in the flesh
well then we've heard that from from
pippa now time to hear from the
the teachers and their side of things
richard sheriff
the executive head teacher of harrogate
grammar school uh what was it like for
you i'm going to ask you what was it
like on your first day back
um well i stood outside the gates uh
today with the
the colleagues who are leading the
school and there was a sense of kind of
joy
fun eager anticipation relief
and all of those together and it was
like watching people
re-reunited with old friends watching
the students come up and they were so
pleased to be in school and really
grateful for all the efforts being made
and doing everything they could to
comply with all the safety things and
how to get tested and so forth
it was just great it honestly was such a
happy positive
day today what's the thing that that
students most said to you do you think
today
i think the thing students were saying
actually was was
not a great deal because during the
course today they were coming in
queuing up speaking to each other coming
in having a brief chat with staff going
through the whole testing rigmarole
and then leaving to come back then full
time so
the conversation was quite limited today
i think the most part they were just
kind of getting over the shock of being
out of bed so early for many of them
see each other and be able to see
teachers again walk into school
it's been such a long time for many of
them so i think with the conversation be
fairly limited i think they will open up
and have lots of conversation when they
come back properly together
in social time and also in in lessons as
you know
you know lewis and josh were saying it
makes such a difference seeing each
other face to face
being able to have that informal contact
with children rather than over
the internet absolutely but it was a
rude awakening though when that alarm
went off
they're not used to that anymore let's
get our first question now from faith
oliver
who's in year 12 and actually joined in
the first episode of covered in the
classroom faithful welcome back to you
what was your first day
like um
well we actually haven't fully returned
to college yet
my sixth form decided it was best to
take a phased return approach
because it was easier to test the sheer
amount of pupils that we have
so a lot of pupils won't actually be
back face to face until the 22nd
however i've been in the whole time
throughout lockdown
and have seen people go to get the tests
to get ready
to come back to school and they've all
been really excited to be able to come
back
yeah i can imagine what's your question
to the panel
and my question is do you actually
believe that it is safe for
pupils right now to be back given that
the sage advice
was to go for a phase return and the
government has opted against that
okay let's put that question to the
panel we're streeting do you want to
answer that question for us
is it 110 safe to be back in the
classroom
110 i mean the prime minister
acknowledged today that
with the return of schools there is
obviously a risk that
infection rates go up and what what
we're all trying to do
is balance risks here we're trying to
balance against the risk of the virus
spreading and
getting out of control and frankly the
way it has done on a number of occasions
but also recognizing that
um the longer the children and young
people are out of school
there is also a consequence both in
terms of health and education there
and we've argued all the way through
that schools and colleges should be
among the the last to close and the
first to reopen because we understand
particularly listening to the panel
members already this evening um
the the difference that being in school
makes so
um i mean we've had arguments with the
government about whether or not they
could and should have done more i mean
we've argued for the vaccination of all
school staff for example
and we think the government could and
should have acted a lot quicker on
things like testing and the safety
measures
but i hope that people will be returning
to school and feel confident about that
and i really do take my hat off
particularly to the school and college
leaders who've been busting a gut it's
not been easy for them this
this last year and sometimes the
guidance has chopped and changed we had
real
difficulties um at the beginning of the
year in january because
the government was literally changing
the rules from one day to the next uh
but hopefully schools and colleges have
had more time now
are ready and prepared and if they are
experiencing challenges we want to hear
about that
we've got to keep the government's feet
to the fire and make sure that schools
and colleges are receiving the support
they need
to keep their staff and students safe
okay we're streaming for the moment
thank you well uh
as we've been hearing there have been a
lot of changes implemented in schools
just bring some of those up for you
uh twice weekly tests for secondary
school pupils that's going to be very
different
face coverings to be worn in secondary
schools and that means during lessons in
the classroom
not necessarily the case for primary
schools that's uh optional then also we
know that
that staffer are going to be tested so
quite a different
environment let's go to our students and
back to faith faith what have you
felt about the changes it's an awful lot
to take on isn't it
i am sorry to completely go against what
wes just said as somebody who has been
in the whole time
i don't see schools as safe currently
not for a lot of young people
testing isn't mandatory my squaring
isn't mandatory
students aren't social distancing i have
had
thousands and thousands of young people
message me on social media when they
found out i was coming on again
to tell me that they are terrified to
bring it home to
parents with cancer to younger siblings
i'm terrified of bringing it home
to my profoundly autistic younger
brother and the government seems to have
no recognition
of what's actually going on there's the
vulnerable category and then there's
everyone else just going
we have no recognition it's terrifying
and so many of us are absolutely
petrified
okay faith thank you very much for that
well dr dubika quite worrying
faith is um not assured that it's
actually safe to be back in the
classroom there
i can sympathize with what faith is
saying because the royal psychiatrists
have always said that
children should be the priority opening
up classrooms should be the priority
however we were concerned back in
september the way it was done
and for the very reason that faith
described so in my clinic i do see a lot
of children young people
who are very anxious for the same
reasons that face talking about
they may have you know parents at home
who are shielding they may be very
worried themselves
um however we are we do feel much more
reassured about the way that's being
done this time
um and it does seem to be don't be done
in a much more graduated way
but it is absolutely important that
there is support for those children
young people who do feel anxious
so we know from what we see in the
clinics and we know from the data that
many children young people are resilient
they will bounce back they will be okay
some have actually thrived during this
pandemic being at home particularly for
example children with autism
but the sad reason for that is because
they have struggled in school before
so it's going to be so important that
those children young people get the
right support when they go back
no very very important indeed well of
course
um there's been a lot of time spent out
of the classroom so attention now turns
to making up for
a lot of that uh lost time teachers and
pupils and of course parents are now
faced with the
enormous task of trying to catch up at
the weekend on sky news the education
secretary gavin williamson said
that nothing was off the table those
were his exact words
let's go straight now to a question from
sadif najmi who's joined by her children
hauer who's in
year five safiya who's uh in year four
and iqra who's in year
one what's your question on this issue
hi um i'd just like to say that first of
all i completely agree with everything
that wes
has said and i just think yeah 100
everything you said and i just want to
know that i know it's been suggested
that longer school days and cutting
school holidays short
would be you know a possibility to try
and get children to
catch up with their work um i'm just
wanting to ask would that not
put added pressure on to teachers who
have already
been through so much and have worked
tirelessly throughout this pandemic
is it fair on them and is it fair on the
children and the parents like myself who
have worked
tirelessly as well to you know ensure
our children are homeschooling every
single day
okay thank you for that that question uh
richard sheriff i think this is one
for you added pressure on teachers is is
that fair
yeah i think some of these things could
represent added pressure on teachers and
that's
not something we need just at the moment
but we are all
absolutely aware of the challenge of
making good on what has been lost
and we generally think the best way of
doing that is not through gimmicks or
sign-backs or kind of sudden um
interventions but really good quality
ordinary classroom teaching
as regular and as quickly as possible
and getting them back to school is part
of them
the comment about longer school days and
holidays it's an interesting idea that's
been thought of before
it's whether the evidence supports that
will actually improve outcomes
if you've got a child in the early years
of primary and they're going to school
for the first time or every day
they're often absolutely exhausted at
the end of the current length of the
school day
to keep them longer is not going to
probably add to their learning
experience
in secondary yep we could have a longer
day it might create more
but again it may create resentment it
may create issues of attendance
and one of the things i think we've
learned during covid is that children
can learn very effectively online not
all the time that should not be
the main form of delivery but i think
there's a possibility by stretching
school day by
using some of the things we've learned
about remote learning to combine that
with great teaching in the classroom
face to face day in day out but also
children doing more of their work
well supported through the media with
the technology we started using
so i think there's a variety of things i
don't think we should close our minds to
any option that will make a difference
for young people
but i think we just have to weigh up the
positives and negatives about every
option we go down
and let's just return to the main thing
if we get children back
as was just said about children they're
resilient
they will bounce back let them get back
into school under normal circumstances
as normal as possible and start to get
that classroom teaching
back that's the best thing we can do for
them now make it look just like it was
before
we're streaming um slightly alarming to
hear that from faith that she's really
concerned about the safety of being back
in in the classroom and we know that
uh in the the other nations it was faced
but we've had this
lump sum of people going back in one day
what are your views
on that do you think that we've
approached it in the wrong way
yeah i think there's two things i'd say
at this stage one is uh we would have
preferred a phased
uh return or at least the option and i
think it's clear that some schools are
are doing that with with the testing
window they've got this week
uh bear in mind that i don't think any
head teacher
or um college principal would be opening
their doors to pupils without the risk
assessments without
being as sure as they can be that it's
safe and and that plus the scientific
advice i think should provide some
reassurance
of course once um students get back i
think it's important we give them
something to look forward to of course
we need to
um focus on the education and well-being
recovery
and i think there's an understandable
concern about catching pupils
up but ultimately this is a this is a
sort of pressure or responsibility that
ought to be
um falling on governments and schools
and colleges we shouldn't you know it's
not something that
children and young people should be made
to worry about at this stage
um so what might that look like i mean
today we've suggested that we should
have
more breakfast clubs breakfast clubs in
every school and college across the
country up to the age of 16 because all
of the evidence shows that has
positive impacts for learning health and
well-being attendance punctuality
it's really good evidence-based
intervention there the government have
put some funding in for
summer activities but i think they could
be much more ambitious i mean after the
year they've had
let's give kids a summer to look forward
to with all sorts of activities from
sports
music drama there are loads of providers
out there who've also had a pretty
terrible year
and would love the opportunity as well
as the income to do that and then
as we've just heard i do think that the
one big hole in the government's
um catch up strategy so far has been
teaching
and all of the evidence shows that um
more teaching better quality teaching is
the best way to
help pupils uh to both catch up and get
ahead
okay and where's let's let's sorry to
interrupt
yeah let's move on because we want to
hear a lot from the students that the
people who are actually affected
and in schools and lewis and josh back
to you you're in in crucial years in
year
um 11 and 13 you'll be preparing for
exams i mean that's
it's difficult enough uh you know
studying for exams
what are you most worried about now
i mean currently what we're most worried
about is the lack of information that
we've received
um i think the way that teachers are
going to assess our grades
hasn't really been clarified and what's
going to be taken into account hasn't
been
um detailed by the government and so i
think currently there's kind of a
prevailing feeling among the students
undertaking gccs and a levels that um
we don't know where our grade is going
to come from um and so
a little bit of clarity on that is
probably where we might worry at the
moment
yeah no it's it's a difficult time it's
a difficult time and everybody
acknowledges that it's been made worse
by
the circumstances that we find ourselves
in
well let's um hear from pippa now
actually pippa's mum
has asked a question on her behalf and
her mum would like to know the impact
of not having sats exams that's right
and how that will affect
education um richard
is she right to be worried or really you
know can
can the kids just just catch up i mean
they've all been in the same situation
so that
is some consolation isn't it
yes and the first thing i say to uh
pippa in year six is don't worry about
missing your sets
i can assure you that one of any
retrograde effect on you you'll be
absolutely fine
and one of the main functions of provide
good information to help secondary
schools get you settled in
in the right way and they'll be using
other ways of doing that communicating
directly with your teachers to find out
what you're capable of doing
and we'll get past the fact that there's
nothing so don't worry about sets
i would like to speak to lewis and josh
who you know i
i really feel for you lewis and josh
this has been so hard for you
um but i want to also try and reassure
you
and that i think what we'll end up with
doing we're still waiting further
details
but it's very likely that your grades
will be based on a whole variety
different things almost like a portfolio
of work that you've produced over a
period of time for your teacher
so they will have a make a professional
view
of what grade you would have gotten the
examinations based on a variety of
things not one single thing
and nothing um will get in the way of
them making that judgment with good
information
and it is worth saying saying this to
both of you and to all those year 11 and
13 there
that what you do now really matters
you have control over your final grade
still however you've done before
because teachers will be doing work with
you doing a little assessment tasks
and so forth to find out what you can do
based on what you have done not what
you've not done
so please keep working keep going to
school do the work that's been said
because you still have control over that
final grade you can influence it
so i think that's a really positive
thing for you to think of as you go back
and i'm sure that you as students
you know you will show fantastic
resilience you've learned a lot during
this period
you've got the benefit of actually
having guns walk through fire
it just tempered you let's see let's see
what we're doing
let's see thanks very much for that
let's see what pippa thinks do you feel
slightly less worried now having heard
that
yes um although i do think
that i would be missing
an opportunity of an experience of doing
the sax but
i am pretty sure that i will
that it will not affect me i think that
prediction is right
pippa i think you're going to do very
well indeed
now finally there could be long-term
implications
on the mental health of young people
dr dubika we've had much about the
impact of um
these situations that we find ourselves
on the mental health
of young people can you give us your
assessment
as to to how much they might be affected
well we're gradually gradually learning
more and more about what's been
happening to children young people
so as i said before i think the really
important message to get through that
most children young people are resilient
they will get through this and they will
bounce back it's not been easy for
anybody
um and as i've also said there's been
some children young people who have done
a lot better during lockdown because
very sadly
they've struggled in school maybe
they've been bullied about social
anxiety
male conditions like autism and it's the
most deprived most vulnerable children
young people those who are already
struggling before the pandemic
those are the ones i'm the most worried
about so i would see this as a huge
opportunity to try and get things right
for children
young people now particularly the
education system so richard was talking
about the importance of well-being as
well how we need to focus
on not just passing exams like stats and
and learning the three r's
we also need to be thinking about
creativity about physical activity
music all those other really really
important parts of the curriculum
that maybe we haven't focused on so much
over the years
because we have to remember that
although 50 of our children young people
do go on to university
another fifty percent don't make that
and they struggle with learning
and we have to be able to help those
children young people thrive in school
and education and this is a really great
opportunity to look at how we're
teaching children young people
and what we're playing placing the most
value on as well and of course if we
want our children to succeed in
education
we know that mental health and wellbeing
is absolutely central to that
if you don't have happy thriving
children they're not going to perform
academically either
so i really do think we should seize
this moment and of course as well we
have to think about our professionals
so if we've got a happy resilient um
education teacher workforce
we know that the teachers that children
will do much better as well
and the same goes to the mental health
workforce and i suppose the last point
to mention is richard also mentioned
technology
and in my 30 years experience in the nhs
i haven't seen such a huge change in the
way we use technology
and what can be done so quickly so we do
need to adapt that and use the best of
them
in education but also in terms of mental
health and there are huge there's a huge
potential there to increase access to
therapies for many families as well
okay i just want to get a quick one
sentence a bit of advice
for for the students now back in school
it's very different for them
uh where's treating you first
i i think we've already heard the best
advice which is you just do your best
keep doing what you're doing and you
know the worst thing you could do now
is put loads of self-imposed pressure on
you you know i think
i think the rest of the country is
looking at your generation who've come
through this last year with
admiration confidence that you're gonna
do well
and do your best and also just remember
you're in the same boat as everyone else
so everyone's had the same challenges
this year
you've gone over your sentence richard
it's it's your turn
just remember that you're not the covert
generation
you're a remarkable generation you know
talk up what you do
be confident go back and bounce back
you'll do brilliantly
not the covert generation that's what we
should remember uh let's get a final
thought
from one of the pupils on the panel
sofia let's
talk to you about uh what you're looking
forward to
i know it's a difficult time and the
word covid is banded about a lot but as
you heard
you're not the covert generation what
are you looking forward to
well it was really good on my first day
of school because
i got to see all my friends and like if
i had any questions john lockedown i'd
have to um email it to the teacher and
like wait for a response but it's
really nice how i just got like talk to
the teacher and like
no waiting and just talk to her so it's
great to be back
what are you really looking forward to
anything being back being back with your
friends every day
yeah yeah yeah i think so i think so
thank you so much
for speaking to us um so that's day one
of the government's first stage of
easing the lockdown restrictions and day
one
of a new era of learning there are lots
of changes to be made and as we've heard
uh the children and the professionals
are taking it in their stride
so good luck to all our panelists in the
coming months good luck with the exams
with the sats if they present themselves
and all
you're looking forward to doing and
thank you to
our panel of experts thank you also for
watching
good night
[Music]
you